the biden department of justice is
making a risky political move in arguing
and appealing the florida judge's
decision about masks on planes and if
this fails to work this could jeopardize
the ability
of the cdc and other agencies to ever
require
masking or other public health
guidelines on public transportation if
it fails so it is very politically risky
so let's back up and i'll tell you
what's going on
earlier this week a florida judge
decided
that the cdc had overstepped its
authority
with the masks on planes and genera we
call it masks on planes but it's like
masks on on mass transit regulated by
the federal government but let's call it
masks on planes the argument was cdc
overstepped its boundaries and the
argument made by the judge in her
decision
was that the cdc is allowed to put in
place guidelines for the sanitation of
airplanes and that a mask on a person
is not really about sanitation on
airplanes now you could argue well you
prevent needing to sanitize the seats if
people wear masks and they don't put
germs on the seats like it starts to
become a semantic thing but one of the
notable aspects about the decision was
that argument could have been made at
any time during the pandemic and it was
made by a judge now
with just like 10 days left until most
likely the masks would be coming off
anyway although we're not totally sure
earlier yesterday joe biden was asked
should people still be wearing masks on
planes and the republican party and
others made a big deal out of this
answer which joe biden gave
people continue to wear masks on planes
that's up to them
that's up to them saying that is a
personal decision it's an individual
decision it's not for the government to
tell people what to do
and then moments later the department of
justice has appealed the federal ruling
on the transportation mass mandate cnn
and others reporting the justice
department wednesday appealed a ruling
by a federal judge that struck down the
mask mandate for mass transportation
following a recommendation by the cdc
it is the cdc's continuing assessment
that at this time an order requiring
masking in indoor transportation
remains necessary for public health they
will monitor
they will appeal
there is a court decision that is
ultimately coming forward so let's talk
through the different aspects of this
some are focusing on
the biden administration the left hand
doesn't know what the right hand is
doing joe said it's a personal decision
and yet his doj is appealing i actually
don't think that's a that's a problem in
any way we've said before when it was
trump trying to direct the doj on what
to do we would say trump should have no
involvement with what the doj does who
it investigates what it does it should
be just up to the doj so it's a good
thing that joe biden gave us his opinion
well right now it's an individual
decision because at the time it was and
separately
as is supposed to happen at the end of
the day the cdc in consultation with the
doj have said we still want this and we
believe that legally we have a case so
the doj is appealing i don't have any
issue with that and republicans have
been saying oh it's just it's chaos joe
says one thing do you no this is
happening as it should joe biden gave
his opinion the doj is making its
decision in consultation with the cdc
and they will carry forward a legal
argument as to why the masks should
remain
which is their opinion
now what is the risk to the doj doing
this particularly when the mask mandate
may have been ending on may 3rd anyway
we don't know that for sure originally
the mask mandate was through april 18th
there was an extension through may 3rd
cases are actually rising now 25 30
percent it it's not clear whether
medically it makes sense to get rid of
masks on planes but it seemed
politically it was likely coming to an
end on may 3rd anyway
what's the risk to doing this well the
risk is imagine that the doj fights this
as full-throatedly as they can
and they don't get the masks put back on
that could then serve as really powerful
and destructive precedent in the future
imagine we get the next uh the the next
wave you know call it the whatever
whatever wave the sigma wave
and it's the more contagious than ever
it's more deadly than ever and it would
be appropriate to say masks have to be
on at airports and on planes
if this decision doesn't go the doj's
way
there may be a total inability to put in
place a mask mandate when it's like
really needed right now it's like
probably a good idea but listen maybe we
leave it up to people to decide we could
have a situation in six months and 12
months where it's like wow we we
absolutely need masks on planes
and there might be no way to get it done
because of the decision that might be
forthcoming here so that's the that's
the legal and political risk it also
would just look bad
if you know hero trump appointed 35 year
old female judge
uh prevails over garland and the doj it
just looks bad politically and so that
is the risk and we won't know for a
little bit uh what happens but that is
what's going on
major breaking news from within the
world of the democratic party
senator bernie sanders according to aids
has not ruled out running for president
again in 2024
if joe biden doesn't run
there is a very interesting article in
the washington post
senator bernie sanders is open to
running for president in 2024 if biden
declines to seek re-election according
to a campaign memo a top political
adviser distributed to allies on
wednesdays on wednesday and shared with
the washington post quote in the event
of an open 2024 democratic primary
senator sanders has not ruled out
another run for president so we advise
that you answer any questions about 2024
with that in mind this is a memo from
faz shakir close sanders advisor
who managed his campaign in 2020.
the memo was shared by a person with
direct knowledge of its contents on the
condition of anonymity because it was
not released publicly and confirmed by a
second person with direct knowledge of
the contents so many in my audience have
been clamoring saying
2024 will finally be the time for bernie
everybody will realize that it was a
mistake in 2016 for him not to be the
nominee
and it was a mistake in 2020 for him to
be not be the nominee
and or it was stolen from him and 24 is
when bernie will sail to the nomination
and then sail to the presidency
i think that this is a really bad idea
i know many in my audience will be
furious with me i like bernie i
supported bernie in 2016. i supported
bernie in 2020. yes i acknowledged when
bernie no longer had a shot in those
campaigns and said well i'm going to
vote for the best alternative of those
who are left but i'm a bernie supporter
from 2016 and 2020. i don't think bernie
should talk about running in 2024 i
don't even think bernie should be
considering running in 2024 and i'm
ready for the hate
at this point
bernie sanders
has become a perennial candidate in the
sense of the guy who always runs and
never wins
it doesn't mean he never could have won
or should have won or that it wouldn't
have been a great president i think he
would have
bernie will be 83 years old in 2024
his term would start in 2025 he would be
i don't remember what month he was born
in but he would be 87 or 88 at the time
that this bernie sanders term would end
this just doesn't seem if you zoom out
big picture
thirty thousand foot view like the
direction that the democratic party
should go to say okay
we've had
what we've had in the last eight years
we uh we have all the history that we've
had
let's make our nominee after all of the
criticisms of wanting and needing
someone younger than biden
let's go
with the 83 year old
who lost twice
it just doesn't seem like the way to go
and i'm i'm willing to hear other
arguments and i'm ready for people to
cancel me over this
but it doesn't seem like the best thing
for the party
i don't really care about the party it
also doesn't seem like the best thing
for the progressive movement which i do
care about
now who's better than bernie
that's a separate segment we're not even
through the midterms there that that's
that's a different conversation
but it's time
for a new generation to lead not someone
even older than biden who's lost twice
and i hate to say it i these are tough
this is a tough pill for me to swallow
but who's not nearly as popular as
looking at twitter and reddit makes it
seem that's the reality
uh i think it's been enough
and quite frankly i worry that it could
even start to border on embarrassing and
kind of a joke if bernie runs again i i
think that there will be a lot of very
unserious
ah this is this is a joke type reactions
if bernie runs again in 2024 i don't
question the genuine desire of bernie
to
do what he wants to do and that he cares
about the thing i i share it i'm aligned
with him i'm highly aligned i'm not
speaking as an ideologue here i'm
speaking as a strategist
and thinking about what makes the most
sense from that perspective in 2024
with respect this is my view i don't
hate anybody i'm not attacking anybody i
just think this is not the right way to
go so my thought would be
don't run in 2024 bernie i i am ready i
am so ready to hear your thoughts find
me on twitter at d pacman tell me
whether you agree or disagree
any responses to this
that are toxic ad hominems some will be
anti-semitic even though it's crazy i'm
jewish and bernie's jewish but this is
the type of commentary that leads to
anti-semitic replies from summoned miata
it's all going to go where it belongs
straight into the trash but substantive
replies i'm ready for find me at on
twitter at deepakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
i invite you to join the discussion on
the david pakman show subreddit you can
find it at davidpakman.com
reddit that's r-e-d-d-i-t
we now have about 35 000 of our viewers
and listeners participating in
discussions there a few uh notable posts
i spotted this morning one was hey is
anyone else receiving memet oz text
scams and they actually posted a
screenshot of a
text scam they received that said this
dr oz report will change your life yeah
i have to tell you
i don't i i get stuff like this uh also
i get a lot of it via whatsapp
interestingly enough uh
but the i we have no evidence that this
is actually associated in any way with
dr oz nor his campaign a lot of these
things are just kind of like preying on
the
notoriety and name recognition of people
like dr oz and i i think you know report
it block it whatever
but um it it's not clear to me
that dr oz is actually sending out text
messages trying to scam people and sell
them bogus medical reports he does his
bogus medical reporting on his own show
which by the way is it even going on now
that he's running for senate i i really
couldn't tell you but um there's all
sorts of text scams i actually got a
recent one this is let me see if i can
pull this up this is an interesting one
um there's a guy called
there's this this guy in the crypto
world called mike novogratz
um he's i guess he's a gold trader or
something anyway i got a text scam about
that one where they wanted me to
give someone money to mirror the trades
of mike novograt i just reported and
block it right away i just pulled it up
in my trash um that doesn't mean that
these things are actually associated
with the people i'm sure that has
nothing to do with mike novograth so
be on the lookout for all sorts of
different scams but
there's many things we can slam dr oz
for i am not aware right now that he is
actually doing this uh text scamming
another post
reminded our reddit
users of um
a seminal event in david pakman show
history this post says remember that
time david turned out to be a gay teen
with aids i hope i'm not the only one
who remembers now this is not a fun
aids and teen gay bullying none of it is
funny but what was funny and the the
viewer has it slightly wrong about a
decade ago
i appeared in a film
about
something really sad which is
gay teens who are bullied so
relentlessly that they take their own
lives and it's horrible that's a real
thing and that happens
that didn't happen to me
and i was still featured in a
documentary with like an in memoriam
thing where i was
sort of like eulogized in a way
as a gay teen who was bullied and took
my own life and
i wasn't a teen at the time
the picture they used was of me at like
age 27. i i guess i was youthful at the
time i was not a teen
i was not gay i was not bullied and i at
the time was very much alive so that is
an incredible moment in david pakman
show history not a not not a funny topic
um but sort of kind of curious that i
was included in that and uh
yeah
okay thanks for reminding us and then
lastly
michael cohen mentions david in his
latest podcast yeah this is cool many
people may or may not know this
trump's former lawyer michael cohen who
now is playing a really prominent role
in a number of different investigations
into trump and has a very successful
podcast and on and on
he uh he watches the david packard show
he's in our audience it's great and
we'll
we'll exchange messages sometime i was
on his show he was on my show
he sometimes will make some of the jokes
we make on this show that make it clear
he pays attention he was interviewing
kurt eichenwald
and uh he brought me up listen to this
if trump is so trump is president but
biden is president and the guy he's
like yes i i think that's david pakman
uh who was actually doing a video like
that i saw it i saw something like that
too it was with a a husband and a wife
and he just started fumbling around you
know none of it makes any sense and
how can it make sense you can't you know
you it's okay anyway so that that was my
cameo by by uh name drop on michael
cohen's podcast it's a great podcast
meia culpa i do recommend people uh
check it out join the discussion at
davidpakman.com
reddit all right let's get into the one
story that has been most requested over
the last 24 hours
donald trump was interviewed by piers
morgan
trump is soaking wet i mean just
dripping dripping with sweat looks like
a rotisserie chicken i don't he almost
looks like he's been seasoned with
paprika and put under a broiler
in a promo released by the piers morgan
show
it looks like trump explodes ends the
interview abruptly and walks out let's
take a look at this this is a 30-second
preview of a forthcoming interview with
the failed former president okay piers
i'm ready a former president in denial
i'll be completely straight with you
i think i'm a very honest man much more
honest than you actually really yeah it
was a free and fair match you lost only
a four would thank you
i do now yeah excuse me okay
excuse me the most explosive interview
of the year i don't think you're really
i'm not
so certainly from that this looks like
the interview of the year i mean it's
it's hard to imagine anything more
explosive and comical trump dripping
with sweat disheveled
uh telling peers that he's dishonest and
peers telling him this that it looks
absolutely crazy it looks fascinating
the problem is that
there is now the claim being made and
we're still trying to figure out the
truth of it that that promo is so
deceptively edited that the true nature
of the interview is completely different
that it was there were contentious
moments but it didn't end on that note
that the interview went over by like 40
minutes from the 20 minutes it was
supposed to be
and that mostly they got along so nbc
now has put out an article
which as trump releases audio that
appears to refute the claim that he
walked out of the interview over 20 20
questions
an audio recording obtained by nbc news
appears to show that trump's highly
publicized interview with piers morgan
didn't end with trump storming off the
set as edited promotional video clips
suggest instead according to the
recording which was provided by trump's
spokesman the two men thanked each other
and laughed at the conclusion of the
interview for talk tv a subsidiary of
rupert murdoch's news corporation
talk tv is set to debut monday it teased
the interview billed as the most
explosive interview of the year
in a video summary dramatized with
cinematic music it portrays trump as
being angry about the content of the
questions turn the camera off very
dishonest but the audio at the end of
the interview appears to tell a
different story the two men laughed and
thanked each other the recording shows
there are no signs of trump storming
offset
that was a great interview morgan says
trump agrees yeah thank you very much i
really appreciate it morgan says trump
then turns and says turn the camera off
but by then trump was already up from
his chair so what is the truth here i
genuinely don't know i genuinely don't
know uh i'm interested in the interview
regardless to be perfectly frank my
opinion of piers morgan is barely higher
than that of trump's i think
either is capable of extraordinary
dishonesty and the interview as as
promoted it seems almost satirical but i
don't know the truth of that and we'll
have to see it in the full interview
what it appears is that little what
might have been done is controversial
bits from the middle
were edited together to make that seem
like the end
and we're just gonna have to wait and
see now i don't let them fight amongst
each other i i i don't trust either of
them as far as they can throw them in
fact this is kind of a funny story this
new show that piers is doing on talk tv
which is part of news corporation it's
owned by rupert murdoch who owns fox and
news corporation um they've been bugging
me to appear on that show but here's the
incredible thing
the producers of this new pierce morgan
show i don't know if i should be saying
this i don't really care i that they can
hate me they started contacting me
saying hey david
we think you would be a great guest for
piers morgan's new show
okay that sounds interesting sounds like
a publicity opportunity we would love
for you to participate in some
rehearsals for the show
okay i mean
taking time out of my day to appear on
something that's not even going to be
broadcast i don't know but i guess if
like if it gets me in front of peers and
i get to know him and that could still
be worth it
yeah and here's the thing
it's going to be a rehearsal without
peers it's gonna be really like a tech
rehearsal for the producers and the
engineers and everybody to like get used
to running the graphics and the music so
it wouldn't air and it wouldn't be with
peers it would just be like a stand-in
like okay but but listen if you get on
our good side we'll we'll have you on
the show you know as a guest when all
right i guess i'm willing to do it if i
just have to you know sit in front of
skype in my in my studio for a few
minutes they go well actually we need
you to go to a studio across the city
guys i can't do i'm sorry i'm sorry and
this is how they dangle in front of you
and i
eight years ago with other channels i
won't say which ones i fell for this
oh yeah please take time out of your day
to travel to a studio for a rehearsal
without even the host
and then we'll have you on all the time
and then they never do
i'm all set guys
okay uh everything about the production
of this show seems
teeter-tottering so it wouldn't shock me
if piers morgan deceptively edited this
and if that's the case then he deserves
uh what whatever is coming to him now
that being said
it is not uncommon for trump to walk out
of interviews because he doesn't like
the questions it's actually a classic
authoritarian move
you claim that just real tough
interviews are unfair and then you bail
and then you use that to justify only
speaking to people in unopposed rallies
where you just lie lie lie and nobody
can oppose what you say that's a classic
mussolini move uh you can read about
that in history and trump has actually
done it before remember he did it with
leslie stahl on 60 minutes your
president excuse me leslie you started
with me your first statement was
are you ready for tough questions
are you that's no way to talk
there's no way to talk leslie
at this point one of our producers
interrupted to advise about the time
remaining in the interview
i think we have enough of an interview
here hope okay that's enough let's go
let's go
uh
let's go meet for two seconds okay
thanks i'll see you in a little while
thanks
there's that one he also did it during a
phone interview with npr's steve inskeep
when he started getting they weren't
even really like tough questions they
were just
substantive questions trump didn't like
it and hung up the phone remember this
one i wonder the only way it's not going
to happen again
is you have to solve the problem of the
presidential rigged election of 2020 mr
president
one more question i want to ask about a
court hearing yesterday on january 6th
judge amit mehta he's gone okay
so
the peers morgan interview maybe it was
doctored maybe it wasn't we're going to
eventually find out but in all
seriousness trump's inability to truly
be questioned in a serious and detailed
manner by journalists and interviewers
it's probably part of why the republican
national committee has pulled out of
presidential debates my view is let
everybody devour each other doctored or
not whatever
give trump the toughest interviews you
can if you doctored the video
you should get devoured by the press
these are all terrible people i'm
talking about trump here and piers
morgan
and uh i think sunday or maybe it's next
week we'll find out
the full scope of what happened in that
trump piers morgan interview if you're
listening today and you want to see the
clip that we played from that interview
just go to our instagram david pakman
show we'll have it there
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show today i'm going to be
speaking with ward farnsworth who is
dean of the university of texas law
school and also author of the socratic
method a practitioner's handbook it's so
great to have you on today i really
appreciate it
thanks for having me david good to be
here so i talk about the socratic method
with my audience frequently and i think
maybe the best place to start would be
when we say socratic we're there's in in
that word we're talking about socrates
so maybe we can start with the origins
of of why this is this is a method
attributed to socrates and what it is
sure well um
when people talk about the socratic
method in socrates what they usually
mean is the style of dialogue and
discourse and thinking that you see
displayed by socrates in the dialogues
of plato we don't really know much about
the real socrates whether that's how we
talked we know that's how the literary
socrates talk and that's the model for
the socratic method and the model is
characterized by
questions but particular types of
questions meant to elicit certain type
of thinking can you talk us through that
a little bit
yeah i think the socratic method is the
greatest tool there is for for critical
thinking and for testing
people's views it has a lot of features
and they're hard to summarize quickly
but usually what socrates is trying to
do is
work with the beliefs of the person he's
talking to so socrates doesn't usually
say you're wrong
he says can we agree
on this
can we agree on that
well but but if you if we agree on those
things then what about this other thing
that you said it seems like there's a
tension there or an issue so he
basically talks people into
contradiction with themselves which is a
to me a distinctly effective way of
working with people you don't agree with
one of the things that sometimes is
frustrating in the modern landscape is
you might get someone to contradict
themselves but they seem
unable to recognize that they've
contradicted themselves and so for
example we we see this frequently when i
will talk to people who say
that trump is actually the president and
it's joe biden's fault that gas prices
are high it's like well if joe biden's
not really the president how could it be
his fault that gas prices are high
that's sort of the contradiction
but sometimes people seem to lack an
ability to even understand the
contradiction how would the socratic
method address that
well first of all
uh if if they don't think there's a
contradiction
then i and i'm the one using the method
then my feeling is that's on me my
questions have not been skillful enough
or maybe i'm wrong maybe there isn't a
contradiction they don't think there is
one because it looks like there's one to
you but what they mean when they say
donald trump's really president isn't
what you think they mean they mean this
and you think they mean that and so
there's something additional about their
meaning that you've got to get to the
bottom of uh that that
i just think the right way to think
about this is uh always ask whether if
you're not making headway it's really on
them take responsibility and see if you
can be more empathetic and try to
understand what they mean or what
they're thinking that's that's an
important part of the socratic method is
you're trying to get people to come
around to your way of thinking and
before you can do that you kind of got
to come around to their way of thinking
or really understand it and not just not
just like what passes for thoughts not
what not what passes for thought in the
minds of these people you think are
idiots but but how they actually look at
the world and why it makes sense to them
and once you really get that it's much
easier from that standpoint to then uh
bring them around to something that's
more like the way you look at things
one of the things that seems important
in the socratic method is a sort of
humility about our own beliefs and it
seems that the approach of asking
questions
can be humble in a sense because you're
you're really trying to learn more about
what the other person believes even if
your ultimate goal is that you suspect
they're wrong and you want to change
their mind at the same time there's
sometimes the assumption that it's more
persuasive to appear more confident in
in what you believe so is there a
balance that needs to be struck or is it
just not true that it's more persuasive
to be confident
well i suppose it's hard to generalize
i'm sure there are people who are very
persuaded by confidence and not by
humility but the socratic method in any
event is is founded on humility i mean i
know the socratic method sounds
fundamentally like a technique for
questioning other people and for trying
to bring them around and it's very
powerful for that but to me first and
foremost it's a style of thought that if
you're if you really care about these
things you try to use yourself so you're
also you're questioning what you think
and you're wondering if maybe you're
wrong and so uh when you're talking to
people you're trying to help
questioning for them to see things your
way but you're also alert to the idea
that maybe you have something to learn
uh from them and i think that that one
byproduct of that approach is that if
you're humble in that way you're more
likely to make headway with others but
you're also more likely to make headway
and seeing your own uh
short-sightedness which is of course um
something we should all want
can can we talk through in practice how
this might sort of
appear in if it's happening at you know
the thanksgiving table is often the one
people call in they say i know my uncle
believes that let's i mean we could just
stick with my uncle believes trump won
he just believes it was stolen he
believes joe biden stole it and he's
going to bring it up and he's going to
say can you guys believe
what joe biden was able to get away with
and people want sort of a framework with
which they can without upsetting people
without ruining relationships start a
gentle socratic inquiry what types of
questions might we we ask in that
situation well
good question i mean the first question
is you know is it worthwhile to
thanksgiving table to try to chase this
down let's assume it is let's assume it
is interesting we'll assume is but i
just mean you can be socratic about the
value of using these methods in a
certain moment that's but but putting
that to one side yeah um
look i mean to me the goal is always can
you find some common ground can you find
something you agree on that you can then
build from so saying something like uh
uh
you know look what here's what i'm
interested in what would you be willing
to count as evidence
that the election wasn't stolen
or or what's or what do you want to
count as evidence of anything i mean
like like let's just take something
that's less controversial and just see
if we can agree on that how do you know
that somebody else won the presidential
election let's talk let's talk about an
election we can agree on right how do
you know who won that election i'm just
interested i mean i'm really wondering
how do you think about that because in
in a sense we don't know all we know is
what we read in the paper so how what
makes you so sure that somebody you like
ever that ever that donald trump won the
first election
and and let them explain that for a
while and you say okay so that's
interesting so i guess what i'm
wondering now is of those things you
mentioned how many of those things are
not also present
in the election you are worried about
and so trying to find an election you
can agree on before you start talking
about election you can't agree on i
think is is a helpful approach and i
would just use that approach in general
is try to find a case you can agree on
and then talk through what that case is
about and then try to use what you've
established in your in your easy case to
sort of gently ask about the hard case
that's really interesting it seems
there's maybe in thinking about the
empathy component there as well there
might be an opportunity also to find
common ground in this conversation to
say
do do are we on the same page that we
both want whoever really won to be the
president right are we on the same page
that that that's right that's ultimately
what we want we want to know who really
won but that person should definitely be
the president it seems that might also
be useful
definitely but then of course
so after i think everybody would agree
on that that's a good thing to start
with and then then you'd say okay now
now the question is what does it mean to
say somebody really won yeah like do you
what do you mean somebody who got the
most popular vote or do you mean the
person who won the electoral college
forget about trump for a minute just
what do we mean in general and you keep
trying to build agreements on things
once you have these agreements in place
you narrow everything down and you know
i still think that i mean
in these conversations of course you're
always hopefully thinking look maybe
i'll learn something and you can say to
the person honestly let me tell you if
this election was stolen i want to know
i mean i don't want to live under a
stable election i'm sure you don't
either david so if there's any evidence
that this was stolen i
i certainly would be grateful to hear
about it
and i think you can say that i think
anybody can say that and meet it
what about with one that can be
sometimes when the topic lends itself
more to the ideas of experts and who
counts as an expert it can get much more
dicey so for example let's we could
think about coveting vaccines right
where
there's not only a disagreement about
facts there's a disagreement or
misunderstanding about
who is a valid authority
and about the differences between facts
and opinions oftentimes what are
opinions are
put out there as if it is the type of
statement that counts as a fact when
really it's only an opinion and it seems
that it's a much tougher hill to climb
seemingly armed only with the socratic
method of questioning how might would
the would the application be different
in such circumstances
well i i don't think so because you can
still ask questions about other
situations where people defer to experts
like you might say um
let's talk about some are there are
there any vaccines you do take
well why do you take those
uh are there situations where expert
opinions are enough for you
because there are for me and i think
actually most of us defer to experts
sometimes
and so the question is uh when and can
you find a case where the answer is yes
and then what are the features of that
case and then how do the features of
that case compare to the features of the
the case and the case that's in
controversy i think that that's the
socratic idea is you always try to find
something
that's try go move over to an easier
case where you can agree and then
establish things you can agree on
because usually what's going on is in
the controversial case everybody's
judgment is clouded by other features of
it by the politics of it or the the
rooting interests that you have like
almost like as a sports fan
um and so you're trying to go find a
case that's not clouded by those things
and establish your principles there and
then gently move them over into the case
that's giving everybody more trouble
what about specifically when
where the sometimes the struggle will be
when people will call me
i might present
what are you know what i see as data and
reports about a particular issue and
someone will say
well my experience is just different so
it's an anecdote right we're talking
about anecdotes versus uh empiricism and
it's very easy and reflexive to say
that's an anecdote and we need to just
look at we need to look at broader
evidence but people are often pretty
resistant to that they'll say no i mean
listen this is what i experienced and so
this is real to me in some sense
what sort of advice do you have in that
type of situation
well i i mean i think first just just
listen to people i mean nobody's gonna
listen to you unless they feel like you
listen to them so if your immediate
reaction is obvious contempt for their
experience then you're just not going to
be off to an effective start but let's
imagine that you you've done that and i
think at that point maybe the most
helpful way to reason is to to ask
well how do they feel when people make
similar claims
that are anecdotal or about their own
experience
but who they don't agree with i mean you
know because that's the kind of claim
that people can't stand when it's made
by those on the other side so trying to
think of an example i mean that's what i
think in general is if you can flip the
politics in a situation like imagine
exactly what you're saying but imagine
somebody on the other side
making that claim what you know you can
ask me what would you say to them what
would you think of the strength of that
claim i mean wouldn't i i'm not i'm not
trying to tell you how you feel but how
do you think how do you think you'd feel
and of course it's always perfect if you
can think of an actual example
and say well you know what you're saying
reminds me of somebody i knew and that
you may have heard about who actually
made a very similar claim but except
that they
they love everything you hate
and i just wonder how would you work
with that person and say well that
person's just wrong
well i know you think that but they
don't they don't think that so what
would you know i guess i guess what you
probably say to them is their ideas
about what counts as evidence don't seem
very strong
and then maybe you've got an inroad i
mean these are hard these are not
conversations that uh you know you can
expect in which you can expect to turn
somebody 180 degrees the question is can
you make a little headway yeah it seems
that it's although there is a sort of
socratic toolbox that it's really more
of a framework is that fair to say than
a sort of how-to
yeah that's right i mean it is there is
sort of a toolbox there are a lot of
techniques that socrates uses but it's
also just a mindset and a stance of sort
of humility and awareness of your own
arrogance and ignorance you're trying to
uh learn from others in good faith um
so i don't think it's a paint by numbers
scheme for questioning but if you do
study the method in the book the
socratic method that i've written tries
to provide some sort of guidance on that
i think it provides you with an approach
to hard conversations that can be more
productive than just arguing with people
directly and and
uh contradicting them
is there a connection uh beyond just
what seems to be superficially a little
bit of overlap between uh socrates and
and stoicism
well i i would say so the stoics regard
and when you talk about stoicism of
course you're talking about the the
philosophy the the word stoicism in
modern english has a sort of a meaning
of uh grim endurance suffering or
unfeeling and ancient stoicism is a much
richer more interesting set of ideas
than that it's really not what it's
about and i think it's very rewarding uh
body of thought the stoics regarded
socrates as their hero and they thought
they were descendants of his indeed i
think if you're interested in stoicism
uh one one feature of the book on the
socratic method is sort of a meant to be
helpful in helping show what the origins
of the great stoic ideas were because
most of them can be traced back to uh
things socrates said
if we go back to that era and and you
know we think about
uh the trial and execution of socrates
does that tell us something about just
the general distaste many have to have
their beliefs questioned
well no doubt it does i mean the um
it's it's important i think when you're
thinking thinking about
the ancient world not to imagine these
were the good old days of unfettered
discourse you know you can some people
would say socrates was the first
victim of uh cancelled culture he was
like cancelled pretty good i i just
think the way i put it is the socratic
mindset is is never going to be
the majority mindset because it's it's
too contrary to how human nature works
people fundamentally crave confirmation
of what they think by others so
somebody's asking questions that are
uncomfortable is never going to be
popular wasn't popular 2500 years ago
isn't popular now
but i think it's a very noble and
important role and it's also i'd say the
same thing about any individual the
socratic function or the socratic aspect
of your own mind is never going to be
the predominant one because even in the
site even in your own psyche just like
in the social world
it's it's it's never uh the strongest
force you know it's always sort of a
minority position but i think everybody
can use a stronger socratic attitude
within their own self as well as um
finding use in the socratic method when
they're dealing with others
the book is the socratic method a
practitioner's handbook we've been
speaking with the book's author ward
farnsworth who's dean of the university
of texas law school i really appreciate
your time today thank you david great to
be here i appreciate yours
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
generally speaking people who have done
nothing wrong don't ask for immunity in
order to testify or to talk to
investigators our old friend alex jones
is asking for immunity if he is to
discuss his role and knowledge related
to the january 6 trump riots it is not a
good week for alex jones bankruptcy but
a bankruptcy that may be calculated to
try to shield assets from people he's
ultimately going to have to pay money to
which lawyers say isn't even going to
work and now alex jones wants immunity
new york times report alex jones reaches
out to justice department about trump
riot interview the effort by the trump
ally to get an immunity deal is the
latest sign of progress in the
investigation which recently brought on
a well-regarded prosecutor
the federal investigation into efforts
to overturn the election seems to gain
traction justice department has brought
in a new prosecutor alex jones the host
of the conspiracy driven media outlet
infowars and a key player in the
pro-trump trump to stop the steel
movement is in discussions about an
agreement to detail his role in the
rally
through his lawyer joan said he has
given the government a formal letter
conveying his desire to speak to
prosecutors the lawyer norm pattis
maintained jones had not engaged in any
criminal wrongdoing that day
as the condition of being interviewed
jones
has requested immunity from prosecution
now the reason they're giving is he
distrusts the government
so weird to believe
alex jones
believes and knows that he did nothing
wrong
but he is so distrustful of the
government he thinks if he talks to them
they will find some crime to pin on him
anyway
and um
that's why he wants immunity
while convincing federal prosecutors to
grant him immunity could be an uphill
climb for alex jones his discussions
with the justice department suggest that
the investigation could be gathering
momentum
two weeks ago another prominent stop the
steel organizer ali alexander an
associate of jones revealed he got a
subpoena from a grand jury that is
seeking information on a broad swath of
people rally planners members of
congress others close to trump about
what happened on that day
this is absolutely fascinating
now again
in general innocent people don't try to
get immunity as a condition of speaking
to investigators alex jones wants us to
believe it's not because he believes he
did something wrong it's because he
believes they are going to sandbag him
because he doesn't trust the government
now
as in that i spoke to some investigators
about this and they said listen anyone
can always say they're going to try to
find something to pin on me but that in
general
they genuinely if they don't think alex
jones is the top dog right you you want
to use people to get the top dogs that's
the general idea here that why would you
talk to alex jones first and even
consider immunity if you thought he was
at the top no that's the guy you want to
take down so they believe there's people
higher up than jones
if that's the case
you want to genuinely
have a goodwill working relationship
with the witness because that's how
they're going to tell you ideally
everything or everything you want to
know
so
only the most
paranoid person would think
even in a cooperation agreement they're
going to try to sandbag me
it just doesn't really make sense it's
not typically how these investigations
work is it possible that they want to
charge alex jones sure it's possible but
if they're looking to him as a
cooperating witness to get bigger names
they're they're not going to deceptively
sandbag him they might be upfront and
say we're not ready to give you immunity
because we actually do think you might
have committed crimes but let's talk
that's the way things can go that way
for sure but the idea that uh out of
nowhere they're gonna sandbag him with
the most serious charges it's just not
to the advantage of investigators if
they want to get what they think is the
most valuable stuff from alex jones now
at the other side of this
is that this all could be a stall tactic
we've also talked about and we talked
about yesterday that in general there's
lots of people
on the periphery of the justice
department investigation and the january
6th investigation into what is going on
what happened and who was involved with
january 6th and with a midterm election
coming up and with um an attorney
general in merrick garland who is of
questionable conviction when it comes to
really prosecuting wrongdoing um of
higher-ups when it comes to the january
sixth circumstances
running out the clock and stalling as
much as possible isn't a crazy idea so
it is not an illogical strategy for alex
jones to ask for immunity even if he
knows he's not going to get it simply as
a delaying tactic to say i am willing i
am willing but we've got to figure out
immunity first um also remember
that
if he has relevant information
immunity might do more good
than compelling him to testify because
then he'll do what he already did which
is just plead the fifth amendment which
he's constitutionally able to do there's
no there's no question about that
thinking from a practical investigative
perspective you might end up getting
more from giving him immunity than from
just compelling him to testify because
we know what him and eric trump did they
pled the fifth hundreds of times so
another not great week for alex jones
we will see if he gets immunity
someone sent me a video yesterday that i
found fascinating because it reminded me
of someone that i've interviewed on the
show who has since passed away that i'm
going to tell you about in a moment this
is a video i'm going to play for you of
a q anon person
who believes that trump and jfk jr jfk
jr not jfk jfk junior a lot of people
are confused by which jfk
uh they believe that this person
believes trump and jfk jr are currently
the president and the vice president and
one of the delightful things i i love
hyper-specific conspiracy theories as
many of you know this guy also claims
that mortgages are invalid that more
that as soon as you sign a mortgage the
mortgage is paid off if some of our
older listeners might remember who this
should remind us of so let's look at
this clip first
sure
sure
did you know all mortgages in the united
states are fraud
every one of them
everyone is fraud did you know your
mortgage was paid off
your mortgage was paid off
the moment you signed the mortgage
application and they accepted it whoa
you know who paid it off
you did
see you're not a debtor you're a
creditor you just don't know it
you don't know it
they want you to think you're a debtor
and that you're indebted to them
your signature
paid off that loan immediately
and you don't know why do you okay i'm
going to teach you guys why so this
this i don't know why i find this
fascinating so who does this remind me
of this is a great dip into the archives
for some of our younger viewers there's
this guy who passed away in 2019
his name was david wynn miller
and i interviewed him years ago and
during the interview i'm not going to
play it for you now but you can look it
up it's about 10 20 minutes long he said
things that like for example that he is
the king of hawaii as as one example
that he syntaxed the magna carta but
david win miller's big thing was that
you can make yourself a non-taxable
entity to the united states with
something that he called quantum grammar
and the inclusion of extraneous
punctuation marks in your name so like
his name was david win miller but he
would put like a colon before david and
then a dash between david and nguyen and
he believed that by becoming
uh
[Music]
quantum grammar you were no longer
taxable and people tried doing this
stuff and they were they were sometimes
held in contempt by courts so here's a
little bit of what david wynn miller
used to do this q anon guy it seems just
like the next version of david wynn
miller when we
went to school they taught us that the
sentence must be one thought right so we
have a
we have a one venue or one condition of
thought which is the correct parse a
syntax grammar parsee syntax grammar was
a favorite word of his and if you're
looking at this you also see that he has
hyphens between like every word on his
whiteboard that was another thing he did
however in the world of fraud
which means you're going to have
going to the store from the house now we
have two different time factors of from
and two which is now a lie because now
we have two conditions of time
and it's no longer a single thought
sentence
so this generates when you're into fraud
fiction lies perjury false guessing
presumption assumption
yeah
when uh my dad was a psychiatrist when i
did the interview with david windmiller
years ago i showed it to him and i said
what do you what do you think about this
guy he's not diagnosing anyone in any
formal way everybody relax my dad said
this guy strikes me as what's called a
paraphrenic it's not a schizophrenic a
paraphrenic is someone who has a highly
organized set of of delusions
without hallucinations he's this guy's
not hallucinating he just it's a very
organized
sort of like gated set of delusions
and
outside of that they seem like normal
people so sometimes when you have like a
paranoid delusional or schizophrenic
you can't have a normal conversation
with them about anything it's when you
speak them they're very clearly totally
out of touch with reality you can't talk
about the grocery store you can't talk
about sports or whatever
david when miller my dad's instinct not
a formal diagnosis was this is this is a
paraphrenia with this grammar stuff it's
highly organized and limited and outside
of that you you can seemingly have a
normal conversation with a guy here's
one more video from from one of these
weird seminars 92nd degree mason is
because in 1988 i broke the math
interface in all 5 000 languages proving
that language is a linear craziness
algebra right this hasn't been done in 8
500 years of written language
he broke the math language interface
maybe he could fix my toaster when i did
so i was able to unlock the two-thirds
of all the words missing from all
languages
in the world and i can write any
sentence in any language frontwards and
backwards with the same meaning yep even
the maiori languages he's able to write
uh forwards and backwards so
bizarre stuff and the q anon guy it's
like the same thing let me explain
grammatically why
you are really the one who is owed the
money on the mortgage or whatever the
case may be
wacky stuff but the point is
all of this stuff recycles i've told you
guys that a lot of the modern
revolutionary left
sometimes they're called tankies but
it's not a it's sort of a pejorative the
modern revolutionary left
are really similar
to
the 60s era sort of socialist communists
that were really common in in south
america they were in argentina where i
was born and in other countries it's a
rehashing of the same ideas and the same
ideology and the same sort of tone and
tenor
and even the q anon stuff isn't really
new when they get into these
technicalities about grammar and syntax
david when miller did this stuff for 30
years may he rest in peace
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p guys i'm really taking a
lot of hits this week i was criticized
uh for saying that oprah is to some
degree responsible for dr oz because
she's the one who brought him to the
public and someone said that that's
racist how dare i accuse a black woman
of that and now i am being criticized
because i did not issue a ramadan
greeting on monday i guess take a listen
to this
good morning wendy from california with
regards to monday's show greeting
um you know
welcoming back from passover and then
it's like oh yeah and easter
wasn't it also ramadan i don't know i
would like to believe that
you're not
myopic and that you're
inclusive and that
because of inclusion inclusion that
leads to object objectivity
um last week i was concerned
because you thought the native americans
didn't put up enough resistance and now
i don't even know what the hell she's
talking about there so the second part
i felt the native americans didn't put
up enough resistance
i i never said that okay that i that's
completely out of this world but i guess
the problem is on monday i said hey hope
everybody had a good passover or a good
easter it's good to be back and i didn't
i didn't mention ramadan so here's the
deal
i don't know what the hell is going on
as far as religion goes i know about
passover because i'm culturally jewish
okay so that that's why i know about
passover i know about easter because
it's a federal holiday it's on every
calendar
okay i don't know about anything else
going on so if someone tells me it was
ramadan it's not because i i don't in
particular not care about islam
i just i just don't know
march 2nd i looked up march 2nd was ash
wednesday i had no idea i didn't mention
it i just i don't know if it's like if
the stock market's open and whatever on
friday i noticed the stock market was
closed and i was like why is it closed i
looked it up oh it's good friday because
it's easter that's the only reason i
even figured it out um you know this
this coming week this sunday is orthodox
easter i had no idea i i looked it up
and i found it
april 29th is lailat al-qadr i hope i'm
pronouncing that correctly that's that's
a muslim holiday i don't know anything
there's no
let's not read in with malice to things
that are just really no big deal okay
let everybody relax all right i'm not
trying to be disrespectful to anybody
everybody's welcome to watch this show
on any day
regardless of what holidays are going on
on the bonus show today netflix has lost
viewers for the first time in 10 years
their uh stock has absolutely crashed
i lost a bunch of money because i've
owned netflix stock for a really long
time
uh i had forgotten about it and
yesterday uh i guess i lost 40 percent
okay we will talk about what's going on
with netflix omarosa manigault newman
has been awarded over a million bucks in
legal fees from the trump campaign will
she ever actually get it and senate
democratic candidate tom mcdermott
smoked pot in a political ad to
celebrate yesterday being 4 20. all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show
don't miss it sign up at joint.com